من سبعه الى ثمانيه فرق هي العربيه وايضا
الاوروبيه والغربيه التي وصلت الى هنا من
التونسيه الى الارمنيه الى جورجيا الى
الفرنسيه الى الجزائريه ايضا والاسبانيه
وصلت الى هذه المنطقه وهي تعمل من ضمن فرق
متعدده وايضا اماكن مختلفه بالتوازي هنالك
الالاف من المتطوعين والمتطوعات الذين
جاؤوا من عده محافظات الى هذه المدينه
ايضا هنالك المئات لربما 500 الى 700 اله
ثقيله من جرافات وحفارات ورافعات هي التي
تعمل نحن نتحدث عن مدينه برمتها اغلب
الاحياء فيها سويت على الارض لذلك عمليات
الانقاذ يجب ان تكون على هذا المستوى اذا
ذهبت سريعا معي الى هذا الشاب الصغير الذي
اصر ان يخرج على الهواء احمد اساله اساله
ومن اين اتى هو عشقي
تبعنا وكل شيء وجينا منزل
او مع شركه او مع ناس
يشتغل على الارض
صغير شو الدافع الاساسي اللي انتقل من
محافظه الى اخرى